[Musique]
m
alors
non
quoi
[Musique]
parent
[Applaudissements]
quand ils ne sont pas au rodéo leur
passe temps favori
les paysans de oaxaca sont touchants
dans cette terre aride où seuls les
cactus semble s'aventurer pourtant au
pays de ces cow-boys mexicain il est une
plante bizarre aux longues feuilles
rigide et piquante bien plus qu'un
vulgaire cactus ici la gav a été
surnommé l'arbre des merveilles et toute
une population de paysans s'acharne
quotidiennement sur cette curieuse
culture tous les villages de l'état de
oaxaca en produisent ils en plantes des
champs entiers et après dix ans de
patience car la gav se fait longtemps
désirer
il la récolte vaillamment des coups
fatals de leurs machettes
j'ai 83 83 ans et est ce que c'est
difficile de cultiver la gav
oui c'est très difficile il faut
travailler beaucoup c'est très dur très
pénible à partir du moment où on plante
la garde jusqu'à la récolte il faut
travailler dur
ça demande beaucoup de travail
ce n'est pas tant la gav qui obsède les
paysans que son coeur qu'ils arrachent à
coup de barre à mine froidement ils
fendent les coeurs dénudés des agaves et
les brise en morceaux
un travail pénible sur ces drôles
d'ananas qui pèse 50 à 100 kg
[Musique]
on
la cuisson très lente et très minutieuse
est une véritable oeuvre d'art culinaire
elles durent trois jours à l'étouffée
dans un four de terre l'épreuve du feu
est suivie d'un broyage redoutable sous
une énorme roue de pierre la gav
rebelles finira bien par rendre son
trésor
dans ce pays mystique faut-il chercher
la réponse chez les dieux ces divinités
de la nature que oaxaca adoré avant la
conquête espagnole
maya lds aztèques des agaves
n'aurait-elle pas dans sa bienveillance
doter cette plante d'une substance
divine là-haut sur la montagne bleue qui
retient la vallée prisonnière le berceau
des divinités ancestrale s'appelle
montée albane
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de talent ici parce que
les temples était dédié au dieu les a
portés qui s' y avait beaucoup de lieux
c'était naturel la nature leur en donner
les dieux s'il savait à la nuit il
savait le dur et la lune
s'ils savaient à le jurer savez le le
dieu de soleil il savait le dieu de la
pluie le lieu de maïs le dieu du vent
etc
et chaque temple ici était dédiée à
chaque dieu finirons nous par savoir ce
que la gav cache au fond de son coeur
dans les rues de oaxaca les mexicains
eux le savent depuis longtemps le trésor
de la gav
ils en connaissent tous les sortilèges
et les adore
[Musique]
jusqu'à mescal voilà donc l'objet de
toutes les convoitises mescal ce fameux
alcool da gave 100% naturelle qui fait
courir tous à jaca
[Musique]
on dit ici que le mescal et la boisson
des dieux qu'elle ouvre l'appétit et
fait disparaître la fatigue pour les
paysans laborieux elle fait aussi
disparaître par instants une vie souvent
difficile boisson ancestrale le mescal
est très présent dans la vie quotidienne
et économique de oaxaca lemay scanner
partout dans les cantines à ses cafés
mexicains dans les rues dans les
magasins et même sur les murs de la
ville où les graffitis l'on surnommé
l'or de oaxaca solo 17 et une sorte de
cannes traité pour éviter qu'elles
s'imprègnent d'une escale celui qui
réussit à boire un apollo 17
on lui offre dix autres cannes mais
jusqu'à présent il n'y a qu'un français
qui a réussi à tout boire d'un seul
trait on l'appelle apollo 17 car celui
qui boit tous montent jusqu'à la lune
c'est vraiment très bon et qu'est ce que
ça veut dire monter jusqu'à la lune
ça veut dire qu'il est tellement aimé
chez qu'il atterrit sur la lune
complètement saoul vous pouvez nous
faire une petite démonstration
voilà regardez comment il faut s'y
prendre
[Musique]
c'est sûrement l'esprit des dieux qui
souffle sur la vallée dans cette région
d'ombré de lumière la gav millénaire
garde toujours vivant le mythe de oaxaca
[Musique]
et